In Africa, there's another use for mobile phones.
Public health workers in Kenya...
...are using mobile phones to gather health information from patients in remote areas...
...and upload it to the Internet...
...for instant analysis at distant centers.
And it's all happening thanks to Dr. Joel Selanikio.
You can really make a difference...
...using, again, just common modern information technologies.
Dr. Selanikio first noticed the need...
...to better use information technology for health care...
...while working as a disease outbreak investigator...
...for the US Centers for Disease Control and Prevention.
Kinda take the first steps toward using...
...things like pocket computers and PDAs for doing fieldwork.
Dr. Selanikio left his position five years ago...
...to cofound DataDyne.org with partner Rose Donna...
...as a nonprofit organization...
...dedicated to providing sustainable information technologies in poor areas.
And with financial support from the United Nations Foundation,...
...and the Vodafone Foundation,...
...Dr. Selanikio developed EpiSurveyor.
A free, mobile, web-based and open-source data collection tool...
...that is transforming the way public health...
...is practiced in underserved areas of the world.